what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite at tiff 2022 for another
interview for a movie that i liked quite
a bit susie searches
congratulations on this one thank you
thank you so much so much genuinely i
want to say that collider is one of my
favorite places ever and i was just
reminding you that you may have
forgotten but
we did a uh a weird interview where you
said write down your feelings on these
plates and then smash them so you break
away your feelings and um you know my
therapist and i have been chasing that
high ever since so it's been years since
i felt that good
it was like smash away something that
gave you bad vibes i like that yeah and
i think i said i was like yeah trump
supporters and i smashed it yeah
still to this day one of the best videos
that we ever made and it's in slow-mo
troops
yeah that's so cool i feel like uh i
still want to make those videos but now
i shoot a lot of things out of my
apartment because you know post living
at home for three years but i'm willing
i'm still willing to we just don't have
that alleyway studio anymore
so i feel like if i smashed a plate and
anywhere that i filmed now i'd probably
get in trouble i was pretending not to
know what the pandemic was oh that too
okay yeah that was my bit all right i'm
gonna stop talking for the rest of the
interview i got your bit i got a chance
so really i was just so focused on
smashing more plates that it just blew
right past me uh let's get to your movie
uh sophie first thing i have a feeling
you're doing this a lot right now so i
apologize but for anyone out there who
does not know what susie searches is yet
can you give a brief synopsis of
yourself
um susie searches is about a girl with a
true crime podcast she lives in a small
town in middle america
and no one listens to the podcast and
one day this
this kid at her community college goes
missing and she sees it as an
opportunity
to exercise her sleuthing skills
and
then it goes off the rails from there
job well done i want to talk about
spoilers so bad i know it's not the time
eventually we're going to get there
though
so i know this idea started as a short
film
i know the short film didn't come out
all that long ago 2020 but things with
like social media and our perception of
fame change and like a flash so was
there anything in that gap that you
think you needed to evolve for a 2022
audience instead it's a great question
so the short was really just a proof of
concept to show
my ability as a director um the film is
has a lot of tonal shifts and it's
it's a it's a it's a cool tone it's a
it's a thriller
um or a dark comedic thriller so
um
it's a tricky tone tone to maneuver and
so it's really just a way to
limit um the amount of no's i i could
get because i think the industry tends
to be
risk-averse
and so you wanna
make something
as a first-time feature director that
sort of limits
the nose as much as possible that's why
i gravitate towards films like this take
risks or i feel like i care a little
less
given the risks being taken and given
the fact that this is sophie's first
feature film what was it about your
first meetings with her that made you
say like i feel like i am in good hands
with this director pulling off this
concept
it was probably that our conversation
just was like yes and yes yes and uh yes
and i was thinking the same thing and so
then i and it was just like back and
forth for literally i think we zoomed
for because it was smack dab in the
middle of everything we uh
zoomed for like two
three hours i think it was actually
three and a half and yeah we talked for
so
long like my team's texting was like
what's going on was that horrible we
didn't hear and i'm like i'm still on
zoom with this person
and then we went on a bunch of
hikes and um
walks and
just really got to i really did i really
did have to suss out the stitch and see
like do i
trust
this
person right as a new person in your
life and
and
with
not just you being a new person but like
susie being a new person in my life too
this is going to be a long journey and
it and it was it's been years which is
so weird
yeah
how about for you alex anything stand
out
um well sophie's just awesome and her
and her short query was awesome and i
saw that
and uh you know i've told this story a
million times but her boyfriend is named
ryan farhoody and he's a personal
trainer and i was um training for this
other film i did the line and
uh he was like hey you know you should
read this script you should uh do this
movie and i was like sure i'll do it and
he was like you want to read it i'm like
like yeah sure i'll read it but i'll do
it you know sounds cool and you're a
cool guy and just send it to me and then
they sent it i was like yeah it's
awesome and i was like let me talk to
sophie and talk to her and i was like
yeah let's do it and then everybody you
know on my team is like yeah it's really
awesome and i was like great and it's
kind of every every step of the way it's
just been really positive and i was like
yeah i'll do it sounds great that answer
is making me think we we sometimes play
a would you rather game all about
filmmaking and one of the questions i
ask often is would you rather sign on
for a new project without getting to
read a script or without getting to know
the people that you're going to work
with and it sounds like for you
oh though
i'm kidding by the way it was the script
if you can't pick up on my
little don't ever enjoy fire don't ever
explain your hanging i gotta explain my
irony of course i read the script and i
loved it but i just like the idea
everyone's like you know i went to this
process of thinking and and i examined
and every page i color coded and i just
like the idea that i was like
i just want to spread the rumor that i
didn't even read the script i just loved
you loved ryan and i just said yeah
let's do it sounds great
and talk for four hours exactly so i
like being just being like yeah
yeah that's so cool here's my follow-up
to all this happening sophie as an
actor's director what is something
unique about the way kearsey approaches
the work compared to alex what's
something uh as an actor's director that
you know you have to do differently to
collaborate with them we are so we're
such different actors different but
we're sorry i'm not best friends yeah
yeah processes are so different
um which is which is part of the joy is
figuring out
how your actors work and then
molding your
ability to communicate or your
your technique your directing technique
um
to their
what they're needing so um
i would say alex is
he's
a chameleon so i don't know if you you
know you've seen alex he's he i don't
know can i say you're like a little
message yes okay um alex is a little
method and in the best way possible
and so i think for him
giving him the space giving him just
enough but letting him sort of
um
[Music]
really find his jesse on his own i mean
alex
alex really inhabited
i mean from
creating an instagram account jesse
welcome loves peace to
follow
yeah
like subscribe
um
uh love yourself laugh a lot live your
life
and
you know and like creating a new haircut
you got your ears pierced
gained like 28 pounds
gained 28 20 pounds no big deal um
whereas
kearsey
[Music]
she's one of those people her emotional
dexterity her ability to
at one point be laughing with the crew
and then and mind you i'll be like
does she need to i'm like we're about to
shoot does she need to and then i'm like
all right and then of course they call
action and she's
her ability to tap into it
and also it's like it's also [ __ ]
straight yeah it was like it was like
also what the subject matter required
because
kirstie's
really one of my favorite actors i've
ever worked with by far and she's so
amazing in the movie you can see that
but i mean even working with her because
i whatever i was staying in here it's
also like icky to talk about but
my most important thing is staying
really loose and really in the moment so
like whatever's going on if it's in the
car i want to like let's let's utilize
and kirsty will just be talking to me
about some
gossip or something but it's it's a it's
a technique and sometimes i'll be like
you know getting ready for the scene
she's like yeah by the way did you see
how did it and rolling in action i'm
like yeah and then suddenly you can feel
in the movie that i'm not it's not
there's no nerves there's no like you
know we're there we're just there and
what's going on and that is all
curiosity curiously can just make you
right there in the moment she's my
favorite my favorite their their
chemistry on screen
and off screen and off screen
is so
magical and
it's one of my favorite things about
this movie is
i mean editing them was a was a true joy
i could honestly go on and on
about each one of them and you get to
today all day
all day but the next few months
interview because no because the camera
guy has paced back and forth like like
30 times they are ready to wrap us up
and kick us out uh no i still have a lot
of questions to get to go
um here is one specific thing i wanted
to ask you because like i know social
media can get a little bit of a negative
connotation it can be used in negative
ways sometimes but just to highlight the
good corners there are out there can
each of you name something that you
really appreciate on social media and
the internet in general just something
that you have that brightens your day on
a regular basis
i honestly do like to see
updates from
just what i mean what social media was
initially intended for well i don't know
that's a broad statement for me to make
but i do like to see like
the crew of susie searches people like
that
otherwise maybe we wouldn't have been
texting you know you wouldn't reach out
to as much but getting to
keep in touch with people that i've
worked with or
seeing what people like that i do still
care about from high school or something
are doing i do like the brief updates
because the world is moving so fast and
we're all working constantly because
capitalism eat the rich and so it's nice
to
be able to
for me but that's all perspective i at
one point thought that oh my god
instagram or whatever is so toxic and
it's overwhelming me but
i don't really give it that much weight
or power anymore and
i i like to
i pay attention to what i want to pay
attention to you know and food recipes
food recipes food recipes
since when did i start watching animal
videos it's the dodo
the dodo the dodo does an account it's
the best what i don't know i do why do i
know what that is
it's amazing it's an animal thing and
like people say that you know i
unfollowed it because it was i was too
sensitive for it because i follow gay
animals
and they're not doing anything gay maybe
they are i don't know all animals are
gay as far as i know i know
and it's called all animals are gay
animals are gay gay animals you should
follow it it's great i'm gonna look that
up i have been obsessed with um otters
on social media you have to look that up
gay animals
gay animals okay that does sound a
little no it's on instagram stay don't
go on google search i don't know
i think it is i think it's because i
just realized all of the animals they're
doing cute happy things yeah
that's why you should all go follow a
whole bunch of otters on instagram
because literally everything they do is
sweet adorable and just them loving each
other okay i think it's only gay animals
i'm sorry i'm gonna lie that's like my
only favorite that i'm gonna do after
this
account
i'm gonna wind up searching for this and
finding a whole bunch of random weird
things but i'm gonna give it a shot i
know they have a
um
question for you too i'm curious if you
ever thought about this
is there anything else that susie could
have done to get herself a wider
audience for her podcast as is because
it's emphasized that she's really good
at what she does so was there another
route she could have taken or is it just
a matter of like this business and
achieving frame is a bit of a crap shoot
i mean i think we should avoid that
question
seriously i think i think it's a bit of
a spoiler right is there anything she
could have done
is there anything that she could have
done
gay animals
well if only um
well now anything else maybe anything
else i
i think there's so much
online and there's so many podcasts to
listen to and so much to see and so many
people to follow and so like it's
overwhelming how do you separate how do
you decide how do you even yeah how is
your attention even drawn to one thing
necessarily you know we're all watching
animals on different um there's so many
dodo gay animals yeah it's it's an
overly saturated medium
and
you know a small
town girl
that you know isn't that doesn't have a
huge amount of
followers or friends or community
how do you really
how do you get seen
you know how how do you capture an
audience
that's that's the scary thing though is
that there is no answer
like there is no answer to that
situation and that's why we have this
kind of cycle of people going to the
extreme and making decisions that they
know are wrong in order to get what they
think they want most or there are people
like jesse who are just like uh uh
leaking with sincerity and and pouring
his heart out and there's some sort of
charisma um or or some sort of honesty
and maybe a lack of stuffiness or even
an intellectual ability that that is
kind of charming and enticing and he's a
white sorry
and a man
and
what society would say is like oh he's
he's hot and he's like
in that and all those other qualities as
well whereas
susie is charming but
does doesn't have access to the world in
the same way i don't think not just
limited to like her gender or her race
but
in terms of how yes people do invite her
in or create space for her
and that's what we've been talking about
and there's not really space for her
there you know to even like for those
qualities to maybe even like be seen in
her in the same way which we kind of see
in the movie like the world gets to see
jessie they have so much in common yeah
the world gets to see jesse for who he
is and who he desires
to be and
susie's not granted that same
you know
yeah for a lot of her many
many reasons
yeah she's never really thought about
that like that she's living at home she
is going to school part-time because she
has to take care of her mom so she's
working several jobs
you know yeah it's
yeah i've never really thought about it
i've been thinking about it like that
the whole time
you know she's
she's just she's just trying you know
she's just
i i find her incredibly compelling yeah
that's that's what makes all the
difference with this movie is that it's
like extremely frustrating to watch
knowing her reality and why this is
happening and i don't necessarily
condone some of the decisions that she
makes but the point is good i know why
she makes them and that's what makes her
compelling films and that's why we're
all sort of susie and that's why
or like you know travis bickle or you
know some of my favorite lead characters
that are or to die for you know there's
a lot of people that just
are are complicated and i like movies
that even lean on people being
bad or you know having these sort of
unsavory qualities because then
i feel free to find pieces of myself in
them where i don't see myself in the
guys with the capes as much yeah and
that's why this is a cautionary tale
you know about
our society's current fixation
with insta celebrity and how it can lead
good people with positive intentions
astray and
yeah i agree that that susie is
just human you know and she's fallible
and she's
she's just
she's just you know i don't think she's
surviving but like
people yeah we all are we are
i'm searching
i'm searching
kind of uh breaking that out and
applying that kind of thought to your
filmographies is there any film that
you've made in the past that because
there and it's good that there's so many
films out there but there's so much film
and television out there that it's hard
to break through is there anything that
you two have made that you think
deserved a wider audience than it got
for whatever reason alex i want to hear
your answer
like everyone i mean everyone i feel
like
is uh
i don't know it's it's it's who cares
like i i mean i just feel like you gotta
make art not because i think if you
start getting into oh more people should
have seen this or whatever you're
already on the wrong path at least for
me i just feel like
who gives a [ __ ] it's so hard to make
good art and art that means something to
you it's like and and i feel like
sometimes people think oh get off the
soapbox we all want to do well but the
truth is like
yeah i want to do well but at this point
it's so much worse to be in something
that does well that you don't really
like or doesn't really feel good then
you know it's like how
sometimes
you know the best food or something not
everybody likes or something but it some
people just go crazy for it and travel
to conventions for that's what i loved
about pig like truffles is this
community of people who are who will
literally kill and steal pigs for this
thing that like i'd never even tried
before the movie and i just i don't know
i just think it's literally i'd never
tried it and then i became an actual
obsessive person but um i don't know i i
just like i just
i really don't like the idea that
were actors have any sort of like stake
in how many people see it or whatever i
just it just doesn't matter the movies
that have done the best are have matter
the most it just you think about like
like nobody saw raging bull or king of
comedy and whatever like scorsese didn't
win best director until the departed in
whatever 2004 it's just like it just
doesn't make any it just we have no
control over it so you got to just keep
working and keep doing your art and i
don't know i just like gives a [ __ ] but
my answer is uh is the cat in the moon
yeah
which collider gave me the nicest review
in the whole world so thank you collider
i don't know who wrote that but they're
very smart she's like she's like i
didn't write it for sure
uh what about for you kirsty
well i'm not gonna say anything now that
alex just inspired but he did get such a
good perspective
all right at the end also throwing
castle on the ground last time we were
here
i love your work in that and imogen and
nev as well i think yeah you were
exceptional i take back my answer
i like six movies to list
no i'm totally kidding i'm kidding i
mean i don't it should be about the
process though it should be about
you know because art is objective and
you can never control the outcome so you
just
you make something that you hope
resonates with a larger audience
and then you know and then you
you let it go
not that we actually have any control
but this is why i love what i do so much
because i find something that i'm deeply
passionate about and i know that like
every single angle that you could help
something get out there to an audience
that it might connect with is important
so that is why i sit here and i blab
about your work all the time oh thank
you thank you so much i'm not letting
you off the hook though oh i'm still
sitting here thinking as well
i don't know i mean sweetheart was seen
by a whole lot of people but i'm
obsessed with that movie i don't really
have i don't really even necessarily
like pay attention to i just live in my
world of um yours is so inspiring that
way i will say like she really no like
actually kirsty is someone who is so
about the art and so doesn't care or
know what happens and i actually think
it's like your job like this is why
collider submits you to go no this is
important we need to get it out and us
to be like oh thank you you know but
it's kind of not our job to pick this
should have done this and this should
have done that you know and i think it's
actually impossible and the second you
start thinking that you start making the
wrong choices wrong choices and i feel
like has to be so miserable yeah misery
you want to die you all have the right
mentality i take what you just said
about our work very very seriously and
when it doesn't pan out i take it
personally and get deeply hurt that
everyone's not watching the things i
adore oh my god i love that that's so
cool this is where all of my gray hair
is that's why we need you yeah we need
you oh god um
is anyone yelling at me to wrap do you
need me to rap yeah damn
all right it's a relationship all right
let me ch oh man all right i don't want
to spoil anything but i'm going to get
mad at myself if i don't at least ask
this question and ask you to answer it
cryptically
do you think at the end of the movie
susie regrets anything she's done where
she would go back in time if given the
choice and made a different decision to
start
personally
um
[Music]
ah well i guess i can't go into detail
um
yes i think that she would have gone
about things differently i do actually
yeah
i think she's good at looking back
and um
i think she's a good problem solver
and
she's
good at
uh she i don't know a problem good
problem solver and she's good at making
proper choices and split second yes
decisions and so i think that when she
looks back at how things went she would
be good at going oh i could have done
this or i could have done that and if i
would have said this and i would have
said that or if i would have oh maybe i
could i should have moved this piece
here and that would have gone there and
it turned out like this like i do think
that she would look back at it like that
do you know yeah and that's why again
she's just surviving she's looking at
this moment she's saying
what do i do what do i do what do i do
okay i'll do that yeah you know and so
that's why the ending is also
it's what it is because
i think in that moment
what's playing more than anything is ev
from the very beginning of what we see
in the film to the end every single bit
is playing in her mind and she's
fixing she's like that's where i'm
that's what i could have done and this
is yeah it's so hard to i want to like i
think it's so bad dumping that question
on you but that was a great question
that that last shot is just absolutely
superb i can't imagine a better last
shot for this film for this story i must
let you go
i didn't cut you off no no no that was i
the the the joy of storyboarding
is
um prepping i'm someone who thrives on
preparation so do you yes shocker do you
love a storyboard
you should have brought your binder your
binder should have been she had a binder
she'd be like i did picture that your
face would look like this in this thing
i'm like well that's not me
that's a picture of kevin kline i was
like so i don't think i'm gonna be able
to look like that
it's the exact like it's down to like
such detail you have to share some share
some of that on instagram oh you should
it's very though
it is on my instagram if you scroll but
it's hidden you have to scroll through
but it's yeah um so i'm gonna go stalk
your instagram and i'm going to find gay
animals yes and then you're gonna go
talk about cat in the moon to spread it
out to an even wider audience that's yes
on the ground
i have like 500 other interviews but i
have a whole uh
movie list from this one
i got it covered don't worry i have to
let you guys go thank you so much for
being here congratulations on susie
searches thank you everybody out there
keep an eye out for it thank you go
break all of marvel's plates now yeah
let's do that i like that